Halloween is usually a fun time for kids
going trick-or-treating for candy and
sweets but for kids who live with food
allergies it can be a little scary
staying safe and feeling included
Tiffany Leon is a registered dietitian
with food allergy research education or
fair to talk about the teal pumpkin
project and how we can all help kids
with food allergies have a safe and fun
Halloween good morning thank you for
being with us you know more kids than we
realize I think have food allergies or
food intolerances so what are the
challenges Tiffany for this holiday
you are absolutely right in the U.S 1 in
13 children have a potentially
life-threatening food allergy that's
that's roughly two in every classroom
um and traditionally Halloween there is
candy there are so many different Sweet
Treats involved
um but a lot of those Treats have some
of the most common food allergens in the
U.S so nuts milk egg soy wheat and even
Sesame and so a lot of children that
have food allergies don't feel included
in Halloween or ear can participate you
actually have a unique program called
the teal pumpkin project what is that
about
the teal pumpkin project was started in
2013 by one of our support group leaders
and we're so proud to to support this
project but all you have to do is place
a teal pumpkin on your doorstep and this
raises awareness of three allergies it
lets trick-or-treaters know
that you're participating in the in the
teal pumpkin project and you are
offering non-food treats so bubbles
stickers stencils I offer playing cards
last year so on our website there are so
many resources we have printable signs
different activities I gave some ideas
for non-food Treats but um just to give
a couple more pencil Toppers glow sticks
are a fan favorite we have recipes for
allergen friendlies you know Cookies
Cakes pumpkin treats
um and last year we all we launched an
interactive map so if you are
participating in a teal pumpkin project
you can add your house to the map and
this way other trick-or-treaters in your
neighborhood can start to plan their
route and and see who else is
participating in the in the event so you
can log on to our website at
foodallergy.org and you can see all
those resources that I mentioned you can
have access to the map
um and hope to see hope to see your
household participating this year
such great tips and you can find teal
pumpkins at all CBS stores and lots of
other good information as well and
here's some other tips to keep your
trick-or-treaters safe if they do have
food allergies don't allow them to eat
candy while they're trick-or-treating so
that you have time to look at the labels
on those treats sort through the candy
with your child so you can teach them to
search for allergens in Foods skip candy
and treats without ingredient labels if
you don't know what's in it they
shouldn't be eating it and have safe
treats or even small toys and things
that you can trade for those unsafe
candies and you don't want to punish
your kids you just want to let them
navigate a different way to have a fun
and safe Halloween that's good for them
so they're not upset don't have upset
tummies or you don't have to go to the
you know the ER you don't want any of
that you want them to have fun just like
everybody now supposedly don't a lot of
parents go along with their kids
trick-or-treating I think but sometimes
kids go in groups and parents aren't
along so I think you got to send the
rules out with them yeah when they bring
that candy home don't Chow Down yeah
good luck with that yeah living with
food allergies I can imagine is is tough
all year round